being a human can be confusing it can be
hard to understand who you are that why
you do the things you do hard to feel
good about yourself when you live with
all of your flaws and afflictions hard
to feel important in a world with others
who have their own sets of problems
often too preoccupied with their own to
care about yours and more often than not
because of all this it can feel like you
are all alone when we feel like this it
can be very easy to lose our belief in
love to feel as though we do not deserve
it we might find ourselves
subconsciously sabotaging or pushing
love away every time we get close enough
to touch it because not until we learn
that we are all inherently worthy of
love and are able to love ourselves
unconditionally will we ever be able to
accept love from someone else and not
until we accept love from someone else
will someone else ever be able to truly
love us and make us feel a little less
alone learning how to love yourself
allows you to understand what love
really is and how it works
loving yourself does not mean that you
think you're better than others it does
not mean that you are always happy and
it does not mean that you think you are
perfect it means that you know your
flaws and struggles but still value and
appreciate who you are what you have and
your efforts to do the best you can and
make the most of life despite it all
when you understand this for yourself
you understand that the same applies to
loving someone else you understand how
to both give love and accept love the
truth is we don't need any permission or
achievement to be worthy of love we are
all alive and regardless of where we
came from and what we have done or gone
through being alive is the only
mission you need to feel like you are
worthy of being alive the inability to
love one's own self and embrace the
unconditional premise of love is one of
the biggest reasons why people struggle
to find and sustain successful
relationships it is why a person might
get irritated by the subtlest of their
partner's quirks why couples might fight
over silly trivial things why couples
distance over time or leave out
important parts of who they are and what
they want in life why one might betray
the other and have an affair or why when
the initial lustfulness of a
relationship goes away often the love
dies with it all because one or both
individuals don't understand and believe
that they are worthy of love and
therefore they act out of the insecurity
and desperation that the void of love
creates you simply cannot give someone
something that you do not have and you
cannot accept something that you do not
believe in from someone else if you do
not have love for the self you do not
have any love to give to someone else
and if you do not believe you are worthy
of love you will resist anyone's attempt
to give you theirs you will think that a
person who claims to love you must be
deceitful or crazy or just hasn't had
enough of a chance to see you for who
you truly are
or perhaps they have perhaps you are the
one who hasn't seen yourself for who you
truly are
[Music]
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder